see when you make a sequel you have to
double down in your promotions or you
just get buried by infinity war hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my non-spoiler Deadpool to review so no
worries I'll be explaining what my video
schedule is gonna be for the movie for
the rest of the week at the end of the
video if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos but as you would expect from an
intro clip like that it blew my
expectations away and I'm someone who
likes to follow these movies through
development I just find it fascinating
to see how the ideas come together and
what it ends up looking like at the end
we are living in an era of misleading
trailers so the Deadpool movie did kind
of the same thing that infinity war did
with misleading trailers although they
didn't quite take it to the degree that
Disney did with that fake Hulk all of
the characters that you see in the
Deadpool trailers are characters that
are in the movie but the plot of the
trailers is completely different from
what the plot of the actual movie is so
from a story level going into this I
just expected it to be standard sequel
fare oh they're gonna put x-force
together it's gonna be great we'll find
out what the team will look like going
into the x-force movie which is gonna be
happening next year but suffice to say
when you find out what they actually do
with that team you will be completely
blown away in a hilarious way but also
in a really cool way so it's almost like
they turned everything from the first
movie up to 11 and refined some of the
jokes so he's making fun of infinity war
in that intro clip they took shots at
all of the big studios so a lot of the
DC and Marvel jokes that you've already
heard wound up being in the movie but
they go way beyond that there's way more
than that they take so many shots at the
x-men franchise if you remember the way
they use those x-men characters during
the first film like it was a big joke
that they didn't have any money so they
were like where are the other x-men why
only these two x-men they took that joke
to its logical conclusion like you will
be blown away at some of the stuff that
they were able to include in this with
the budget that they had they had
already started to shoot the movie when
the Disney Fox deal was going on so
there isn't a whole lot of that in the
movie and you probably heard about the
deleted scenes that I talked about
earlier there was a little bit of Disney
stuff that they made Ryan Reynolds take
out but if you're worried about them
pulling their punches this movie
definitely earned its R rating so like I
said everything turned to 11 the
violence the comedy the
folks about other franchises the cameos
so without giving anything away there
were some amazing cameos in the way they
included them are relatively obvious but
just in case I would recommend you not
get the giant soda the first time you go
see it so you don't have to go to the
bathroom in the middle just in case you
might miss it but when these things and
people pop up they'll be relatively
obvious and there'll be some of the more
notable things that people will be
talking about at the end of this week
when everybody else gets a chance to see
it so I know you're all probably
wondering how to Josh Brolin feel
because we just saw him as Thanos during
infinity war what his his cable-like
what are the x-force characters like
because we're gonna be getting an
x-force movie if Josh Brolin was amazing
as Thanos I felt like his cable was a
very distinct and very cool version of
the character I mean he's a great actor
all around this just proves it after
seeing him as both Thanos and cable his
performance of Thanos along with what
the Thanos model actually looked like in
the movie probably one of my favorite
Marvel character actor combinations in
the history of Marvel movies but he
found a way to make his cable feel
authentic relatable and gave him a heart
too and the trailers don't really do him
justice because they mostly use him in a
very Thanos type way like if you
remember theano starring the infinity
war trailers he's just coming like this
unstoppable force for the Avengers and
they don't really convey the heart that
they actually gave him during the real
movie they do change some of cables
comic-book backstory they changed some
things about the characters from the
comics but for the most part the x-force
character origins are largely authentic
to the comics and most of cable is
authentic to his comic book story but if
you remember how the first Deadpool
movie changed his origin story just a
little bit I mean it's fairly true but
they embellished some things about Ajax
and that Weapon X offshoot program same
thing for the x-force movie so just a
couple details about cable and then
Julian Dennison was actually a pretty
amazing performance too in a couple
really unexpected things from his
character so I don't want to give away
any big plot twists but when I first
heard that he was cast I couldn't
imagine who they would be using him as
and he's actually a pretty important
character the trailers just kind of use
him as more of MacGuffin like we have to
save the kid Cable wants to kill the kid
they find a way to pay off both of those
storylines because cable is a hero
Deadpool is a hero but they're fighting
each other in a lot of the
trailer footage that you've seen so far
so obviously at some point they have to
come to terms and help each other out so
the Julian Dennison character is very
critical to that and I felt like the
actor did a really good job with the
performance for someone that's so young
usually I'm kind of dubious about child
actors and films but he did a great job
Rob Delaney's Peter character is great I
don't want to give anything away about
him but he's much more than a gimmick
but the character totally works with
what they're doing with the rest of the
team and the narrative puts him to great
comedic use negasonic in the new serge
character were really fun
they gave her a much bigger storyline
that she had in the first film obviously
Colossus was used for laughs for the
most part but he got to do some really
badass things so that's one of the other
cool things about the movie they did
spend a little bit more on the CG and
the action scenes so they did a great
job of testing the full limits of his
abilities in the most comic book way
possible seriously if infinity war was a
really big comic book movie with some
big comic book moments that they paid
off with the Infinity Gauntlet the
Deadpool movie does the exact same thing
with x-men characters things that you
would never expect them to do so while
infinity war is definitely gonna make
way more money than the Deadpool movie I
feel like they'll just be a couple key
moments during the Deadpool movie that
people will be talking about way more
than infinity war it's just that there
are great movies I would give them both
a z' for slightly different reasons
because they're both trying to do very
different things like they're both big
team-up films Deadpool is more of a
send-up of that infinity war is more of
a genuine drama film with a lot of funny
moments in it so while an infinity war
was amazing because it was the
culmination of ten years of filmmaking
in 22 plus films because we have
Avengers 4 it's still kind of like the
second part of this deadpool found a way
to be unique while at the same time
being a big sequel movie because
everyone was worried when they started
to develop it and you may have heard
about some of the behind-the-scenes
drama with the original director Tim
Miller how he left the project because
he and Ryan Reynolds disagreed on what
the sequel should be let any of your
fears be laid to rest I feel like what
they ended up with was the right way to
go so it was reported that Tim Miller
who's an amazing director wanted to make
a more straight-up polished big action
summer sequel a fun summer movie in Ryan
Reynolds felt like they should
stay smaller and be more like the first
deadpool movie so the reason why I think
Ryan Reynolds was a little more in the
right on that even though the movie
probably changed throughout the
filmmaking process is is because you're
never gonna be as big as infinity war
like his joke that I included at the
beginning of this trailer you're always
gonna get beat out by infinity war
because Disney has more money to spend
then youth they have more characters
more big a-list actors that are starring
in it so the best way to win in a fight
against infinity war is to not tried
Deadpool makes the correct move of doing
what he does best and that's taking the
piss out of all these big franchises
while at the same time giving you that
big team-up moment because of the
x-force characters so we can get into
plot twist when I do more spoilery
Easter Egg videos later this week but
there are some very creative use of
infinity war level twists during the
movie but they are very spoilery so I
don't want to talk about that until
everyone has a chance to see the movie
so I almost forgot a lot of you were
asking about post-credit scenes there
are multiple post-credit scenes be sure
to stay through the credits there was
even a deleted one that was so
disturbing but sounds so amazing that
I'll talk about tomorrow but overall I
was really happy with what they were
able to accomplish I can't wait to see
what they put on the DVD
if the bonus content for the first movie
was great then the stuff that they
include on the DVD for the sequel is
gonna be out of this world
what'll happen is is I'll do my post
credit scene video on Thursday I'll do
my spoiler review on Friday then I'll do
Easter eggs over the weekend in bonus
videos just depending on what you guys
want me to do so if there are various
specific videos you want me to do for
the movie just let me know in the
comments but click here to watch Ryan
Reynolds apologize for Green Lantern
again great clip and you can click here
for more brand new infinity war thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]